what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones the day that we
have all been waiting for has finally
arrived Game of Thrones Season seven
episode one just went off the air and
there is a lot to talk about
but before we get started I want to give
a big shout-out to quid for sponsoring
today's video for those of you that
don't know they are a new app that
allows you to collect stickers cards and
toys for free from some of our favorite
shows on television like Breaking Bad
Adventure Time Bob's Burgers Star Trek
and I think I can speak for everyone
when I say our personal favorite Game of
Thrones
this set provides a ton of Game of
Thrones collectibles and the coolest
thing about this is if you're someone
who likes to use stickers or emojis when
you send messages with this at you can
add the Ned Stark
Tyrion Lannister or Daenerys Targaryen
stickers to your text or you can even
collect cards like the ones I have
already I was playing around with this
at last night and I already collected
over 90 items on here for free my
username is talking Thrones so when you
get the app make sure you add me as a
friend and if I have something you
aren't able to unlock we can even make
trades together or make trades with
other people who are using this app
because there is also a chat room for
the Game of Thrones community who use it
as well I'm going to put the link down
in the description so you can check it
out my username will also be down there
too just in case you forget if you're a
game of Thrones junkie like I am and
you're tired of using the same old
smiley face emojis then you're really
going to love this app and the best
thing about it is it's free use the link
in my description and give it a try and
add me as a friend now let's dive into
the premiere this episode began with the
cold opening where we get a scene at the
twins where aureus stork is posing as
Walder Frey and what I found very
interesting about this scene is Arya
stork appeared to take the shape of
Walder Frey while she was wearing his
face I think we've all been wondering
which characters Arya could potentially
wear the face of based on their height
and weight
but after they'd seen we know that when
Arya where someone's face not only does
she take on that person's voice but her
body shape changed as well I think this
makes Arya Stark an even more dangerous
person than she already was she gave a
toast to all the freemen and she
reminded them that they didn't kill
every stone
which ended up being a fateful mistake
on their part
Aria served everyone poisoned and wiped
out presumably the rest of the men in
house fray but Aria made sure none of
the woman were killed but she did
deliver a bone-chilling line of dialogue
right before we cut to the next scene
she tells one of the girls when people
ask you what happened here
tell them the North remembers tell them
that winter came for House Frey I
absolutely loved that line by aria
that was a really cool way to open up
the very first episode of this season
but let's go to the next scene and this
scene may have been my favorite from the
entire episode which is when we see the
dead marching onto the wall I thought
this was absolutely beautiful and
terrifying all at the same time the
night's king's army looked massive and
he had three giants in his army that is
pretty damn crazy after seeing this I
won't be surprised if we see Hodor and
summer in his army now and I won't be
surprised if we end up seeing ice
fighters and polar bears too this was
one hell of a way to open up the season
as well in my opinion the night king and
his army is going to be knocking on the
door at the wall when this season ends
no doubt about that what was also cool
about the scene was bran was actually
watching them march on the wall bran
watches this as him and Meera are
waiting outside the wall and this is
when Lord Commander Eid greets them at
the wall but he isn't too sure brain and
mirror or who they say they are he
thinks they're actually wildlings but
Bryan had an ace up his sleeve bran has
seen everything and has seen he saw them
at the fist of the first man and he saw
them at hardhome and brain tells them
that the night king is coming for all of
them and this scares the [ __ ] out of Ed
and rightfully so ed knows he isn't
prepared for an attack on the wall and
did he notice the bottom of the gate at
Castle black it didn't have the spikes
on the bottom like the one from the
trailers the spike gate in the trailer
is going to be at eastwatch-by-the-sea
just like I've said before in previous
videos but before the scene ends you can
see edge stare off into the distance
beyond the wall knowing that they are
coming and he doesn't have the manpower
or weapons to stop them but this leads
us perfectly right into our next scene
and this is when we get our first scene
back at Winterfell where Jon says he
needs the maesters to look for records
of dragonglass because he knows they're
going to need
as much as possible to defend themselves
against the night king's army now John
does no dragonglass kills them obviously
but he lost all of it at hardhome so I
think what's going to happen is Sam is
going to end up sending John a raven and
telling him to go down to Dragonstone
because there is tons of it there
because obviously later in this episode
Sam makes a pretty big discovery and
sees exactly where all the dragon
glasses on Dragonstone but John also
reminds everyone that they're going to
need men women and children to fight for
them because men are not going to be
enough and John ends up telling tormund
that he needs the wildlings to man the
wall which is a good idea because
without men on the wall they have no
chance of actually slowing the night
king down at least if they had some more
men on the wall they could kill as many
of the others as possible before they
actually breached a wall which they're
going to do regardless but they could at
least slow them down and diminish his
army somewhat but tormund does agree to
help reluctantly and this is when sons
and John have a disagreement about what
to do with the Karstark a number castles
Sansa wants them to be punished and the
castles given to loyal men while John
wants the family to keep their home
because it's been in their family for
centuries John says his decision is
final
what you made things tense for a bit but
John get the children to pledge their
sword to House Stark the course target
numbers must come to their aid whenever
John calls upon them the north must
remember and it kind of seemed like John
and sones that were going to have a
serious problem over this but the next
scene they talked it out the best they
could
Sean's a did tell John that he was good
at ruling and the men do respect him and
they even shared a quick smile together
but this is when they're interrupted by
maester wolkan who was the Bolton's
former maester John ends up receiving a
letter from Cersei letting him know that
she is now the queen and they need to
bend a knee to her or suffer the fate of
all the traitors sons is definitely
worried about this and worried about
Circe's wrath but John's only concern
right now is what marches beyond the
wall but speaking of Cersei we see her
and Jaime next Cersei talks about how
they are surrounded by enemies and you
got to admit it Cersei went full Tywin
in this scene she talks about a dynasty
lasting a thousand years
same as Tywin told Jaime years ago
circe also tells jamie that their
brother Tyrion is now handed the Queen
to the Narus so now we know that Cersei
does know Tyrion is alive and in a
position of power
Jaime knows that they're going to be
laying that dragon stone any minute and
this is when the stage gets set for them
to sack Highgarden Jamie talks about not
having enough food to feed his army and
he talks about Highgarden having the
resources this is going to be one of the
main reasons Jaime ends up going south
to take Highgarden over Jaime also knows
that they need allies too they've
already gotten word that the phrase were
wiped out by someone someone who isn't
their friend and we know it was already
a Sorak but Cersei was already prepared
for this she tells Jaime she has a new
ally on the way
Cersei says this is a stronger and
better ally because they have ships and
they are good at killing and she's
talking about none other than your on
Greyjoy exactly who most of us knew was
going to show up I'm going to be honest
with you though I thought he was going
to show up for the first time with some
prisoners with him but this is where
Euron decides he's going to attack his
enemies and Circe's enemies Euron also
takes a couple low blows of Jaime he
says he wanted to marry the most
beautiful woman in the world and here he
is standing right in front of her with a
thousand ships and two good hands
Jaime obviously didn't like this Jaime
doesn't like you're on or the Greyjoy's
anyway Jaime might end up killing your
own if he continues to cross the line
which we all know you're on well he's a
savage
but regardless Cersei declines his
proposal for now but you're on we'll be
back with proof of his loyalty he's
going to return with some prisoners
Cersei would love to get her hands on
which is going to be the sand snakes
next stop is at the Citadel where we pay
a visit to same wall Tarly in his time
at the Citadel so far looks pretty damn
miserable he's emptying out more bedpans
than books he's reading as same as
putting some books away he notices a
closed-off area in the library and he
knows whatever is locked up behind the
cage is exactly what he needs to be
studying he has plans of getting his
hands on those keys but before he starts
breaking the rules just yet we meet
archmaester Marwan next him and Sam are
dissecting a human body and Sam asks
about access
to the locked up files Sam says he's
seen the army of the Dead and Marwin
actually believes him personally I think
Marwan is going to end up helping Sam
archmaester Marwan knows that there must
be some truth to all the stories about
the long night and the stories that Sam
has I have a feeling they're going to
uncover all the answers needed to
survive the long night but there may
have been some foreshadowing and they
seen also Marwan tell Sam that the wall
has always stood in every winter that
has ever came has ended basically saying
that as long as the wall stands they're
going to be fine but we all know that
wall is going to be coming down very
soon Sam ends up taking the keys and
grabbing some books anyway because
sometimes when you want [ __ ] done you
got to do it yourself but we then go
back north to Winterfell where Brienne
and Podrick are training in the
courtyard and we also get a short chat
with songs in Littlefinger and songs
that makes it very clear that she wants
nothing to do with Littlefinger I'm
actually surprised little fingers going
to stick around while he's being talked
to like that but he still wants songs
are really bad but Songza knows this and
she plans on keeping him around so the
Vale is going to stay loyal and in the
north
scientists have really just reached out
the sweet Robin herself and get little
finger out of the way immediately Lord
Royce is already there at Winterfell if
they would just kill a Littlefinger now
and get it over with
everything would be all right in this
next scene we get our first edge Shireen
cameo as Arya heads north she overhears
someone singing and they're actually
Lannister men who are in the area
because of what happened at the phrase
news has already spread pretty quickly
about what happened and I think at first
Arya planned on killing these Lannister
men you can see her kind of scanning the
area looking around at door sword seeing
where everything's placed I think she
really planned on killing these guys but
they treated her so well I think she may
decide to let them be I was honestly
very surprised at how friendly they were
to Arya a girl traveling alone in the
woods like that usually doesn't end well
and when Arya said she was going to kill
the Queen I was expecting some trouble
to brew right away but nothing happened
yet but this scene may not be over with
just yet either but it was very
interesting to note that Arya did say
she was going south to King's Landing
to kill the Queen because I think most
of us thought she was going to head
north to 1fl right away so I'm kind of
curious how this is going to play out
because I do not think Aria is going to
kill Cersei this season so something
must happen on her way there that makes
her change her mind and head home it
could be the reunion with Nymeria that
makes her decide that she needs to be
with her pack but we'll see in the next
episode I assume but in the next scene
we go way up north and get our first
glimpse of the Brotherhood without
banners and a hound and there was more
snow here than at Winterfell they
stopped at a house during their journey
and the Hound doesn't like being here he
remembers this house this was the same
house the hound and Arya stopped that
and had stew this was the same house to
hound beat the man up and took his
silver which didn't sit well with Arya
but the Hound did tell Aria that they
wouldn't survive the winter and he was
right when they get inside the house
they actually see their bones in the
corner of the room the daughter died in
her father's arms and the Hound and the
Brotherhood without banners have an
interesting chat next down basically
just wants to know how the help berry
keeps coming back to life and that's
where Thor's asked the Hound to come
over to the flame and look into the
flame and I think we all knew what would
happen next
Thor's basically shows the Hound what
the hell is going on and what is going
to happen just like Melisandre used to
show Stannis her visions in the flame
you could see that the Hound was
terrified by this he actually sees
eastwatch-by-the-sea where the wall
meets to see he sees the castle where
the Nights Watch her and he can see the
wall he can see thousands of the dead
marching and he sees a mountain that
looks like an arrowhead which must have
something to do with the night king
sigil now the Hound knows they are here
for a reason now he knows that they must
go north and try to stop them the
Brotherhood and the Hound are going to
go to eastwatch-by-the-sea exactly where
the spiked gate is that was in the
trailer and I can't wait to see this
mission beyond the wall they're going to
need Daenerys dragons to take out those
giants or else they are pretty much
screwed Giants are hard to kill when
they are alive you're not going to kill
a giant with just a small torch you're
going to need a damn dragon it's
got them but before their scene ends we
get a pretty cool shot of the how next
burying the father and daughter which is
kind of a callback to the whole
gravedigger theory he feels bad they are
dead you can tell that the Hound is
becoming a changed man and after what he
just saw in a flame I really don't blame
him but we go back to the Citadel next
where Sam and Gilly are looking over
some books when Sam discovers exactly
where the dragon glass is on Dragonstone
now Stannis told Sam that there was
obsidian there but now Sam knows exactly
where to find it and he's going to tell
John immediately but before the scene at
the Citadel completely ends we get one
more shot of sand making his rounds in
the infirmary and this is when we see
Jorah Mormont ladies and gentlemen he's
still alive but the greyscale is
spreading quickly but jor is only
concerned in that moment is whether or
not Daenerys has arrived
and this actually scares the [ __ ] out of
Sam he has no idea where Daenerys is but
we do and that's where we go next as she
is arriving on Dragonstone with her
entire crew and they look pretty damn
cramped on that little ass boat but this
was a cool scene Daenerys finally making
it to her homeland she's dreamt of this
day happening and now it finally is
after waiting six seasons the day has
finally came Daenerys being in Westeros
now with her big-ass army and Dragons
changes everything and it also feels
good to have Tyrion back in Westeros too
Tyrion is that his best in the West but
I'm wondering if Melisandre is here
already I'm kind of thinking she is but
when Daenerys and company get inside she
quickly starts to redecorate when she
works down Stannis is flag and she walks
into his old war room a Gon's old war
room and she asked Tyrion shall we begin
it's time to actually start planning the
invasion of Westeros the stage is now
getting set for season seven the chess
pieces are starting to move around and
set the tone for the rest of this season
Jon knows he needs to get dragonglass
and demand the wall The Hound and the
Brotherhood without banners know that
they need to go north of the wall and
the Nights Watch and bran know what is
coming and Cersei and Jaime knows that
Daenerys is going to be a dragon stone
any minute they know they need allies
and supplies and Daenerys is ready to
take [ __ ] over but I have to be honest
with you
this episode wasn't quite as good as I
was hoping it would be but it did have
its moments I think my favorite scene
was when we saw the knight king's army
marching with the Giants I thought that
was pretty damn terrifying what else was
cool though was we got a better
understanding of how the faceless men's
magic works when Aria wears a face her
body size does change along with her
voice which means she may be able to
become anyone so I think that's very
interesting to take note of and of
course Sam is trying to figure [ __ ] out
right away which is nice because we
don't have much time now I'm not going
to discuss the preview for the next
episode in this video I'm actually going
to make another video tomorrow and talk
about that and other things that we can
expect to see in episode 2 so leave your
comments about this episode down below
let me know what you thought about
everything in this first episode was
there things that you liked things that
you hated whatever the case may be I'd
like to hear from you and before I go I
just want to say thanks to the sponsor
of this video over at QuIDD once again
they have created a really cool app that
I think all of you would enjoy
especially since all of you are Game of
Thrones fans but they also have
collections from Breaking Bad and Rick
and Morty and all the other shows that
we know and love but the best thing
about this is it's free like I said
before you can collect all sorts of
things on the set you can even chat with
other fans of Game of Thrones on the app
and you can also make trades with each
other in case someone has a corridor
sticker you don't have but you need to
finish your collection you can make
trade offers and end up having all
different collections and use them to
send to your friends and family all
kinds of cool and funny messages through
texting or whatever else you use the
link is down below in the description
along with my username that way you can
add me as a friend check it out I think
you're going to like it and I also want
to thank all my patreon supporters as
well I appreciate all the help and
support you have shown me in the channel
into everyone else I love you too thanks
for stopping by and watching the video
I'll see you all down in the comment
section bye